on today's show we talk about balancing
working at home with raising a small kid
we talked to a young man whose fiance
does not want to take his last name
and we talked to an awesome mom whose 11
year old daughter is in gymnastics
and she's not putting in the work we all
think she should be right parents right
stay tuned
what up what up this is john with the dr
john deloney's show
grab a chair grab something to eat let's
hang out
hope you're doing well i hope that
you're being kind to hope
that you're finding joy in the morning
optimism in the afternoon and even
though things are hard and rough
and you're figuring it out every day
hope that you're hanging in there
and i'm so grateful that you're with us
on this show we're going to talk about
your relationships your mental health
what's next parenting freakouts
we're going to talk about this in a
previous show
recently i talked about how i
was having a good morning and then i
just opened the freezer
and there my wife had stayed i'm not
blaming her
but in my defense she had stuffed a box
of thin mint girl scout cookies
and i wasn't going to and i closed it
and then as i walked away it was just
going
hey come back and i came back over
and over until i just kind of laid there
in a quasi-diabetic coma
filled with shame right before that show
james came in here eating this giant
muffin of a chocolate strawberry covered
thing of sadness slash goodness they
call it it was
labeled strawberry chocolate bread which
is
so deceptive cake
but i got it for the antioxidants from
the strawberries in the chat we all lie
to ourselves on this show by the way
over and over again but right after the
show james is like
how are you giving me because i was like
hey this is a health and wellness show
man why are you bringing this cake trash
here
and then i proceeded to admit that i had
not had a great morning of
self-discipline and so
what i'm doing now is i'm admitting that
i also out of shame i lash out at my
friends
in people who i care about and love so
i'm sorry james i forgive you
to all of america we just modeled what
healthy forgiveness looks like
did we well i modeled it you modeled
what asking for forgiveness looks like
i didn't ask for anything you just
offered it i just told you i'm sorry
and here's the thing good folks this is
going to end up in my weekly report
it's going to have some comment like man
john's being rude about me on the
internets
so sorry to everybody but james modeled
what a
healthy forgiveness kind forgiveness
could look like
if this wasn't such a prefabricated
situation
so hope you guys all are happy and then
of course
kelly's going to the gym after this to
make us all look bad so there you go
all right so let's get right to the
phones today let's go to emily in
chattanooga emily what's going on
this is the dalone show how can i help
hey dr john i just wanted to say thank
you so much to you and kelly for taking
my call today
thank you so much and by the way i just
started the whole call off weird of
course you know what show it is you call
or
you called that i made it weird so hey
what's up how can i help
it's all good i may have forgotten who
knows yes um
so yeah i am an entrepreneur with a
two-year-old son and my question for you
is
will working while he's awake and
playing create anxiety in him
i want a quality connection with him
it's my main focus but i am
traditionally just struggling to get my
job done
um even with waking up early and staying
up late
where in your number one
great question right man you just you
got my head spinning here
who who told you that you're going to
create anxiety
in your son oh
the internet um the internets
i bet they said you could also solve it
with essential oils didn't they
they did um something that like not
giving
direct eye contact them um especially
like when they're babies and when
they're growing up will
create anxiety in some level and make
them feel like their focus
is drawn or something and so i've worked
it up in my head where
i feel like if i even look at my phone
or look at my laptop even for a second
that he's going to
just be um a basket of anxiety gotcha
all right so you're somebody who loves
their kid and wants to do right
and like all of us you went to the
internets and they told you what a
terrible
mom you are and what an uh
awful job you're probably doing okay so
is this your first kid
yes how old two you told me that right
two years old okay are you married are
you doing this all by yourself
no i'm married okay what's uh dad's role
in this deal
my dad or my dad oh my gosh my husband
is this is the dr freud show too
go ahead yikes yes my husband works out
of town
and he works really long hours so he's
usually home
by around six and he's home on the
weekends he's really involved he
understands that i work from home and so
he has no problem taking my son outside
playing with him he's really supportive
of what i do and of our kid um so
yeah he's kind of i don't want to say
along for the ride but if i say hey i
need to do this
he's there for it very cool so what does
what does home look like and what does
work look like
paint me a picture of your work from
home you're an entrepreneur what are you
doing
yes so i am a professional organizer and
realtor um
so the majority of my job is oh gosh
hold on hold on
you're super super type a aren't you
uh i haven't called that before
that's the most other people have said
that about me
it was not in my list and so i do not
totally agree with it but other people
have said that that's awesome okay
so now i'm just getting a fuller picture
of you emily and it's so wonderful okay
so you are an organizer
and a real estate person what does that
mean yeah
so that means that i do a lot of admin
stuff at home but obviously like showing
homes
um and organizing with clients and stuff
i'm in other people's houses
but then when i'm home i'm home if i
don't have child care
um or if i have you know a laundry list
of
things for work to get done marketing
contracts
um just a lot of the office
kind of back-end stuff um then i'm at
home
and working yeah
and so that's those are two businesses
especially the real estate part that is
kind of wonky hours right i mean i
remember having we bought a house a few
months ago and i was
having text exchanges at seven eight
nine at night over deals and certain
things right so it kind of goes and goes
um so what does home look like when you
are off
phones down plugged in with this little
one what's that like
we um do a lot outside uh we're always
playing outside and even when the
weather is bad we're looking for
different things that we can do
um when it's just remy my son
is just us playing at home we're inside
and playing or outside and playing we do
a lot of different technical things and
i try and keep my phone
away in another room and just really
focus on him
very cool so
i'm not going to give credence to the
internets there
is if you live a life that is totally
distracted all the time
your kids will vie for that
desperate thing that every kid needs
both physiologically both spiritually
emotionally psychologically all of it
which is to be known and seen that is a
for real thing
to say it automatically causes fill in
the blank diagnostic i wouldn't go there
but i would say yes your kids need to
have
time with you that is not bound up by a
phone that is not split between somebody
else we call it the scrolling nod right
where you're just like uh-huh and then
you just bonk that ball but you're
really focused on whatever's
on your text messages or on your on your
watch or whatever
so yes that splitting of time is the
challenge
the other side of that is they also need
boundaries
they also need to know this is time when
i'm doing these things and this is when
you go do these things
that's hard with a two-year-old i know
their two-year-olds are just now coming
around to finding out that
that boundary and the third thing is
i loved at a young age and i still do it
now
every opportunity i had to take my kids
with me two
three four ten i did
so do you ever take your kid remy and
put him in one of those child carriers
and take him to
show a house or to go prep a house
before somebody shows up
i do you do that how was that is that
scary weird
fun um it's a little scary but he is
truthfully a really good kid and he
minds really well
um so if he needs to hold my hand he
does if he kind of walks behind us
or in front of us he does if he's unsure
about the environment he kind of sticks
right near us
um but i've done it a couple of times
and he
he seems to do it pretty well i can't
take him when i organize an appointment
um because sometimes it's just an unsafe
environment sure
absolutely um yeah but showing houses
um different things like that i do try
and take them when i can
very cool so here is what i would tell
you is
is a magic phrase for me as a parent
for my wife as a parent and for any
parents i work with
and that is to make as best you can
either or
time either or time which is
i am all with you or i'm all not with
you
i am this is mommy's work time this is
mommy's playtime
and i know that's really hard and so i
have
and there's no data on this one thing
that i've recommended to folks to try
out
is get with the two-year-old and
have them help you make two hats
one is a colorful bonkers fun hat
that is mommy hat and one is
all red right or all a real bright color
and that's mommy's work hat and when i'm
mommy's wearing we're a cat
that's when she needs to have some quiet
time now two is pretty young
two still wants you all the time right
24 7 365.
that will begin to shift in short order
but
that gives the a child a way to see it
so you
your husband comes home and you can say
hey i'm working
and you can still you can be sitting in
bed legs out
laptop on your lap you're typing away
and he can just
feel it you're working versus when
you're just watching netflix same
position
versus when you are writing a letter to
your mom same position right
kids can't toggle like that so having
some sort of
loud demonstrative thing this says
mommy's working this says mommy's not
and then take your kid wherever you can
right wherever you can
get them out of the house to go with you
they will learn how to interact with
other people
other people will be really graceful and
if there are jerks
like they're sure you're showing houses
they're like oh my gosh you brought that
kid with you
don't work with them because they're
morons right
and take their kid wherever you can with
i think there's a lot of long-term
benefits and they get to watch what it
looks like when mommy's at work they get
to watch mommy interact professionally
and kindly with their people
there's so much there and then here's
the the final thing
give yourself a ton of grace a ton of
grace your husband's working out of town
a lot
you got a two-year-old this is a small
season
if there are some times when you are
trying to deal with text messages and
calling and you're trying to feed at the
same time
you're not going to ruin your child
you're not going to ruin your child if
you look up and you realize man we've
done this
five nights this week then yeah you've
got to step back and have some
boundaries with yourself
you can keep up with your amount of
screen time on your phone you can check
in on some of those things
but give yourself a lot of grace you got
a two-year-old and you're doing the lion
share the work at home by yourself
when your husband shows up he's all in
which is so great that's so cool i'm
glad he's doing that
here's one other little thing oh yeah my
son did this and it was awesome
he served it wasn't a babysitter because
he was third grade fourth grade
but what he did was he would go over to
somebody's house and just play with
their two and three-year-old
he would just roll a ball back and forth
play with a big puzzle
but it was why the parent was home
working from home
doing stuff that they had to do at home
to get caught up so the baby had
somebody interacting with them they
didn't have the full cost of a
babysitter those are hard to find
especially in covid
but the my son was in third grade he won
he got like 10 bucks or some tiny amount
of money but he thought he had a million
dollars
the little kid got to interact with a
little bit older kid which was fun for
everybody
and then the the parent got to get their
work done
and could have that one ear out for it
but they weren't bound by it right so
everybody wants so there's some creative
solutions there to
the babysitting babysitter issue that
maybe a babysitter liked
right or maybe a friend comes over and
just drinks coffee and plays with your
baby but you're still there you can deal
with the crises but
finding those little bitty interim
solutions can be cool too
but on the whole try to come up with
either or time give yourself a lot of
grace
you're not going to ruin your child the
child's in a home where they mommy loves
him
reads to him plays with him makes
outside time
dad's involved your baby's gonna be okay
be conscious about the screen time be
conscious about it
but be really grateful to yourself
alright thank you so much for that call
emily
you're awesome you're so good all right
let's go to andrew in iowa city what's
up brother
andrew how can i help ma'am hey john
how's it going all right dude what's up
um so my fiance and i are engaged
and uh we're scheduled to get married
here in july
okay and i'm having trouble convincing
her to change her last name to mine
sweet okay i feel like i feel like i've
got her boxed it
but i was wondering if you could help me
out with that yeah
so first of all never box in your person
you're going to marry
right yeah that's a losing proposition
everybody loses when you try to box in
another person especially one that you
love
okay so walk me through this um
y'all you ask her to marry you and she's
like yes i i will
and y'all get excited and then she's
like bt dubs i'm gonna keep my last name
yeah so she um so she comes she's a
single child like a
single child in the family like only
sibling right
okay so she wants to hyphenate mine
last name with hers oh she wants to keep
she wants yours but she just wants yours
to be part of a bigger name
yes okay but and my argument is well
it's still not the same
okay because i wouldn't have to agree
you know
um hyphenate my name either
and i was just like you know i can't the
kids names wouldn't be the same
either if it's if they're going to have
my last name
okay catch where i'm going yeah i do
so why does this why is why does it
matter to you
i because historically in my family
everybody even in my neck of the woods
like
i've only noticed until recently that
some people change the last name and
some people don't with the age of social
media
okay um but historically my family the
bride takes the groom's last name and
that's kind of
how it is i mean i haven't really
understood why
or i wasn't explaining why that happens
or why that is
or like why or i've never even
heard of the struggle of coming to that
realization if that makes sense
yeah so um there's a couple of things so
my wife was uh
was a scholar she was a an academician
and she had her maiden name
and she had done some writing under her
maiden name
and then when she got married there
would be
some sort of um disconnect between the
person who wrote under this name than
the scholar who's writing under this
name right
and so i'm the one who actually
encouraged her i said man just keep your
middle name and we happened to all work
at
at the same university she was a
professor and i said man this is going
to get real confusing with
multiple dr deloney's walking around why
don't you just go buy your
i was the one trying to get her to go by
her maiden name just just for the
separation
of church and state right i wanted my
students to be able to say man
dr so-and-so is the worst and
not feel like i can't talk bad about
your wife because that's one of their
teachers right so
she didn't do it she said no i'm like so
we actually had the opposite
conversation y'all are having
i've also heard it in broader circles
about just as you mentioned there's no
reason to do it other than
tradition and i love my last name and i
don't like your last name
i don't know i want to be married to you
but i don't want to associate myself
with your family
and i want i'm the only kid i want to
keep this last name going because
we didn't have any sons to follow that
same tradition so
there's a bunch of different patriarchal
reasons why we just take the last name
and
the woman loses her name and her
autonomy all these other all these
reasons at the end of the day none of
that stuff matters any more than
why do you want her to take your last
name and why does she not want to
yeah and for me i just want it to be the
same because i feel like it's in the
same pool we're in the same
you know everything's the same and it
doesn't add any confusion to anything
and she wants to keep it because she was
an athlete in high school and in college
and i was just like you know
if you get into those hall of fames you
could go in as that last name because
i didn't know you before that happened
and i think that's kind of fair because
i wouldn't expect her to do that
so uh for me i just wanted to be
everything the same and
here's the thing the everything's the
same for you is easier because
for you nothing changes and for her
everything's different
for it to be everything the same for you
does that make sense
yeah but i i do get
man this is just the tradition i didn't
even think to that we needed to think
about this
right so walk me through what happens if
she chooses to hyphenate her name
i got a sense from you there's a
tradition there you don't even know
anybody in your community that does that
is that going to make you feel like less
of a man and it's no shame if it does
i'm just
i'm i'm trying to drill in a little bit
here does that make you feel less than
not really i just feel like it's
kind of a control thing and not that i
don't want to have control over her per
se but like
i don't want to be not
unified in decisions if that makes sense
yes that's where i'm going is this
is a bigger conversation because for
somebody it may feel like a power move
for somebody else it may feel like
they're not going all in right and for
somebody else
they've had regional or
national acclaim under their name
and getting married means they're giving
that up
right and it's gonna they're they're
being absorbed into one person which
they are
right it just makes this whole thing
messy which i want to get beneath that
which is where you are which is
is this making you rethink how you all
are going to have conversations about
hard things
for instance i want to spank my kid
we're not spanking our kid i don't care
what you say
or i want to live in this neighborhood
i'm never living in that neighborhood i
want a
two-story house i want a one story right
these conversations will be will go on
for the duration of your relationship
forever
something tells me that if you're having
this conversation
there's something else beneath it
that makes you go what is that
i i don't know i just
[Music]
i just want to make sure that like we're
all
all in on the same page and
i just don't i can't put a
finger on it i can't really narrow down
what that is
what's another argument you've lost
before
um i don't know i'm a pretty easygoing
guy so i don't like
you know i don't so does this hurt the
fact that you said hey i really
this means a lot to me and she said i
don't care not that she didn't care but
that she's
so reluctant at best okay
steven hyphenate let me ask you this at
the end of the day if she says hey
i'm keeping my maiden name we're getting
married is that a deal breaker for you
not really it's just like it seems so
not abnormal for my
historical my for my family tree i guess
yeah
and what about for her if you say hey i
i it means the world to me
that you do this this the traditional
way that we've done this
and you take my name
is that a deal-breaker for her i don't i
don't think so
but it just gets it's this conversation
just seems like
it doesn't ever go anywhere yeah you're
exactly right
and i think the prob the reason it's not
going anywhere
is because nobody's being honest about
the root here
and the root here is you both have put
on the table this means a lot to me and
the other person hasn't moved and so
this is not about last names anymore
although it is it's more important about
whoa how do we make decisions in this
family what's the 5149 what is
compromise going to look like what does
um like i said earlier when we get into
bigger batter issues as we move on to
our how are we going to do this
how are we going to make these calls and
here's what you got to do before you get
married
you're gonna have to sit down with a
with a premarital counselor
and i want you to navigate some of these
communication issues some of these
values issues
some of these belief issues and more
importantly i want you to come up with a
game plan for how you're gonna work
through some of these things
i don't personally have an issue either
which way on
the last name thing i've got friends who
are musicians who are married who have
different last names
but i think legally they may be the sa i
don't know how any of that stuff works
with them i just know i call them
different last names out in public
and i know that i tried to talk my wife
into it for a publishing reason
but it didn't occur to me that the
downstream challenges it would cause
um the other side of that is i also know
it can
really feel like somebody's not all in
and i can
also feel like hey if we're just doing
this for tradition so you don't feel
weird
this means a lot to me and so every
couple is going to have to make this
decision for themselves
every couple's gonna have to get in a
room and come up with the architecture
for how we have hard conversations
how we disagree and then how we come to
terms with
the the outcome
but i want every guy especially to hear
this
just quote unquote i just want things to
be normal
tends to mean you get your way i just
want things to be the way they've always
been
tends to mean somebody loses their name
they get their voice squashed and you
feel good about where you're at
and so if you feel yourself saying why
can't things just be the way they were
that's a good conversation to say well i
need to learn some new skills i want to
dig in this a little bit deeper because
there's something bigger going on
i really appreciate your vulnerability
here andrew it's hard to make this call
and to say hey i'm struggling with this
and i don't really
i know why i just wanted to be normal
and easy let's just move on
i appreciate your heart man that's hard
to say out loud and i also don't want to
dismiss the fact that y'all have a hard
conversation because this is bigger than
just
the last name and to everybody out there
going oh my gosh can they just get over
no it's a big deal
and you don't get to choose what's a big
deal in somebody else's heart and you
they didn't invite you into their
relationship to comment on it right
but you guys got to figure out the hard
conversation architecture asap before
you get married because the
conversations that y'all are going to
have
in your in your marriage are only going
to get harder and harder and harder
thank you for your vulnerability brother
all right let's go to angela in toledo
ohio angela what's going on
not much how are you all right all right
how are we doing
i'm doing good i'm doing good thank you
so what's up
okay so i have an 11 year old daughter
who is in competitive gymnastics we
spend a lot of time
and money doing this and my husband and
i
are not seeing i guess the level of
effort we would like to see from her
and we're kind of just wondering how to
go about
approaching that with her and if there
is a time to say
we're done or if we need to let her make
that choice
you are the only parents in the united
states of america having this problem
right now
i just want you to feel isolated and
alone in this okay
thank you thank you wow okay
so for a few minutes can i make this all
about me
and walk you through my situation
i promise i'll come back to you okay
okay there is nothing more annoying than
somebody being like hey will you help me
with something and i
and they respond with sure let me tell
you about my life um
okay so i'm gonna preface this with this
i am exhausted and annoyed by
the quote-unquote passion conversation
right
i worked at universities for so long and
i would get these 18 and 19 year olds
that would say i want to be
a singer or a guitar player i'm just so
passionate about it
i want to be a doctor i'm so passionate
about the medical field
here's the thing you become passionate
about what you love and you love what
you're good at
and you're good at what you practice and
unless you're an oddball like my wife
you practice what you were made to
practice as a kid
right okay you had to go through this
because you
learn how to practice and learn how to
stick with something right
so that's my overall disclaimer and then
i'm gonna get personal
in eighth grade i was i've been this big
since i was like seven
okay so in eighth grade i was not a
great football player but i was pretty
fast
and at the end of the year i told my
parents hey we moved up to high school i
went to a super 5a high school in texas
i think my high school had three
four thousand kids it was a lot it's a
big place and
i told my parents i don't want to play
and my dad said you have to play you got
to go one more year
and i want you to to give it your best
so i did at the end of that year
i said hey i want to be done with this
this leveled up here in high school it's
a much more competitive it's a
there's a bajillion kids out here and i
don't want to do it
and the next season my mom said you're
gonna do it
you're gonna stick it out one more year
that next year
i began to grow into my body some
i found some significant success i found
some great coaches that poured into my
life i found some
great teammates and that started a
love affair with the sport i became a
two-year player on
varsity got some extraordinary
experiences that i never would have had
more importantly i learned how to be
coachable
i learned how to not take things
personally but how to change my
behaviors
i still exercise to this day using some
of the techniques
and practices that i learned back when i
was in high school right
so i am a product of parents who would
not let me quit
now here's the other side my wife was a
just a a phenom at basketball
as a freshman she was a stud they were
having conversations about
playing on varsity and she was just she
was really good
and in her words i had to get
out of there i had to quit and i asked
her recently hey
did you ever wish your parents made you
stay like because i'm a product if my
parents wouldn't let me bail out
and she said it would have ended
tragically for all of us if i'd stayed i
had to get out
and she ended up transitioning over to
cross country where again she met a
great team
great great comrades she learned how to
work hard and all that stuff so why do i
say it like that here's the thing for my
parents
they weren't living through me they saw
that i was a better human when i had
discipline
accountable accountability and extreme
physical exertion right they saw that
when i wasn't
playing sports when i wasn't running
around when i wasn't in a disciplined
environment
i was an idiot i was a bonehead in fact
one time my junior senior year my
my dad said like hey let's talk about
the times you've gotten in trouble the
last few years
it's always in the summer or it's always
in that gap between football and track
season right
my little brother was allowed to quit
football it drove me crazy
i called my parents to lecture them
right well then he went to college on a
cello scholarship
right so it's not like he dropped out
and just started playing video games he
transitioned to something else
but they saw in him hey their identity
wasn't in being a varsity parent
it wasn't about them it was about hey we
know our kid well
and we think this is the right thing for
them in this season my
son and i and my wife have had fights
about violin
it's a big deal to me that my kids play
an instrument
music ed's a huge deal for me and it got
to where i thought i was going to come
home and my wife is going to be sitting
on the front porch with a shovel and a
cigarette and my kid was gonna have been
buried out in the yard somewhere
and we had harder and harder and harder
conversations
and so what we ultimately allowed is you
can't just quit on a random tuesday
you committed to finishing this thing
we're gonna have a recital we're gonna
put something on the calendar that
you're gonna prep for
and you're gonna have to learn the
consequences if you don't wanna practice
rock and roll
we're gonna have a practice schedule
we're gonna help you but there will be
people watching this recital
and if you choose to vomit and tank it
you're gonna do it in front of a crew
if you want to practice and be and get
the support i mean we're all in
right and so ultimately my son practiced
we were there to support my wife i i'd
say we
what an idiot husband she did almost 95
of that
and she helped him across here got him
across the finish line
and then he's taking a semester off no
violin
my marriage is better their relationship
is better and we're just taking a break
okay
so why does this matter to you we've got
to find this balance
so every parent i know is struggling
with this
with i played team sports as a kid and
most of us played team sports because
our parents wanted us to because it was
a thing for them
and we want to have this this want them
to work hard and we wanted to learn
these character things
and so the big question i want you to
answer number one is
why do you want your kid to do
gymnastics why is that important
honestly gymnastics in itself is not
important okay um i like
i was very competitive my husband was
not i
gained a lot from the team aspect
and the growing and the discipline and
all of that
my husband is not competitive at all
um and he's very laid-back he said that
with some disdain do you wish he was a
little more competitive with life
okay all right but sometimes he wishes i
was a little more chill so i guess it
evens out
okay but um for me
it's she goes out there when she's
at the practices and she does work and
she gets proud of
herself and she says i want more mom
and then she goes to a meet and if she
doesn't do well it's like
picking her up for four days after but
instead of like doing something about it
she just sits on the couch so have you
have you all helped her draw the link
between
practice and hard work and success and
competition
we have tried um we've had these
conversations
unfortunately she's one of these girls
who everything comes very easily too
and so she's like well if it doesn't
just happen then it's not supposed to
happen
but we've had conversations about do you
want to continue
do you want to stop you know it's your
call
and every time she's like yeah i think
so and then we get there
and she falls down and we say well now
is a great opportunity to learn and to
grow and she's like
maybe tomorrow gotcha okay what do we do
with this
so when you presented this to me
you had an roi investment in financially
and an roi investment in time yes
and i want you to take those off
as as anything to do with raising a
young daughter
okay okay so take those things off the
table
cost doesn't matter time is unlimited
right
which we both know neither of those
things are
what would happen to the dynamic of your
family if you took this summer off
from gymnastics
i think she would
almost be lost when it comes to what do
i do now because it does take so much
time
but i think eventually after a while it
might become
more relaxed because it's not the let's
go we've got to go we've got to
be here you've got to be there and um
what does she
what is it what gets her excited what
does she love
she loves planning um
i have no idea where she gets that from
by the way none at all i bet you've
already have a spreadsheet on how this
is going to pay for college don't you
okay so she loves planning what does
that look like yes
well she she's mapping out her future
and her plans and she's setting up her
goals and her stepping stones how old is
she
by this time she's 11. she's 11.
she's 11. she should not be mapping out
her life strategy
i'm telling you she's very very like i i
want to go here and then here and then
here and then here
but you realize that she's using grown
up words and none of that is real
none of it's true i understand and when
her life is about an
it is fulfilling an roi on time
and money that's how you have to
formulate your existence when you're 11.
yes has she ever heard and i'm i'm
making you feel guilty here and i'm
sorry but not sorry
okay has she ever heard you guys say hey
this takes a lot of time
or we're really busy or this is really
expensive are you sure you want to do
this
um we don't typically talk about the
financial aspect of it
um but she is 11 and she does sometimes
they will hand her like a paper that
says you know
we're going to order this leo and it
cost this much give this to mom and dad
she does see that okay um she also does
hear that because a lot of the other
parents will talk and then they talk
and sure they come out in the lobby and
then it's right there
so so here's the here's an what i would
think
is an easy solution here
and i saying easy not existential it'll
be hard
it'll be hard for you because you feel
there's a part of you that's gonna feel
like
if i don't keep my foot on the gas my
daughter's gonna turn into the my
husband
who i love but come on he's gotta go
jogging right
and if he would just do this i could see
so much potential in him
and he may not say it there's gotta be a
part of your husband that's like
dude i just want a daughter who can
chill and laugh
and just come on man and suddenly your
daughter
whether y'all one or two or not is
absorbing both messages
and she's becoming a proxy war for you
two
and the battlefield is gymnastics right
and i'm speaking way over dramatic here
okay
your daughter knows that she loves you
and knows that she wants you to go do
these
fun things but here's the thing i want
you to come up with an alternative for
her
and see if you can talk her into it hey
what if this
this summer we just took the summer off
of gymnastics
you got to do a thing what dream
anything what would it be
girl scout i don't know what's cool so
i'm gonna say things you're gonna be
like you're such an
out of touch idiot father but i don't
know if it's girl scouts
hey daughter this summer you are
responsible for planning the weekly
schedule and we're at home
i want to see a map of it you're going
to plan the chore list you're going to
plan the vacation we go on
we're going to use your planning skills
and we are going you're going to get to
have
a dynamic you're going to help with a
family budget you're going to help with
these things
or um two summer camps you get
and if she comes back to you after a few
days and says i really really want to do
gymnastics that's when you can have the
hard conversation about
it doesn't feel like it feels like
you're opting out
and it feels like you don't want to do
this and we're getting to a point now
where if you don't practice gymnastics
you can get hurt really bad it's not
like soccer right
where i mean you're just running around
the ball you can fall you can get hurt
if you're not practicing hard right
and when you're 12 that's when your co
like the people around you start growing
into their bodies and they start getting
good real fast right there's going to be
an escalation here
and so let her feel the consequences of
what you're telling us with your actions
is that you're not really in
and that's super okay and we love you we
want you to do something that brings you
joy and happiness and peace
not feel like we just gotta keep making
you do this and so let's
take the summer off let's do this thing
let's play soccer you gotta do a thing
you become the family planner for the
summer we're gonna pay you a dollar a
week you're the new family planner
you and your husband are gonna have to
figure out how to love each other again
because suddenly you're not gonna be
driving all over the place you're gonna
have money falling from the ceiling
because you're not paying for all this
stuff
but at the end of the day i don't want
you to feel like
if you miss this one thing it's over
it's out
it's done okay i want you to look at
three different people in my family only
one
my parents knew i need this expression
i need this interaction i need this
accountability i need this physical
exertion because they knew me well
they let me drop something else i got to
drop baseball but i had to keep doing
this
and it ended up being the right thing
and with my brother
they knew he's gonna he's gonna
transition to music this is just
not his thing he's coming home more
defeated than he is
coming home inspired he doesn't watch
football on the weekends he's not
checking the the
espn to see how the gymnasts are doing
right
but man he has a thing for music and my
brother's a prodigy practices his butt
off and he's
he's still to this day one of the most
talented musicians i know
and then my wife who was a prodigy at
basketball and it just wasn't for her
and she went to her parents and said
i've got to be out and they said we
support you
full on and then she transitioned to
cross country where she was pretty good
wasn't the all-star but she's pretty
good she enjoyed it and she's a lifelong
runner now
and so this idea that 11 year old is
projecting the track of their life
whoa man slow everybody down let your 11
year old be 11
let her play and be silly and have
outdoor adventures and go for
lazy walks with dad in fun routine
driven adventures with mom
and you all figure these things out
together
challenge her with taking the summer off
let her
exhale because the worst thing a kid can
do is feel like they are enduring
something
so that their parents will be okay and
this may mean you and your husband are
gonna have to have some hard
conversations about what do we actually
want for her what does she need what
does she not need and your husband may
have to give some
she needs some more discipline she's got
to step up and
learn that she can do hard things and
you guys are going to call it out when
it happens
hey you're doing really hard things you
can do hard things
and you are going to have to slow down a
little bit and know you know what
if she decides hey gymnastics isn't for
me we've put a lot of money into this
and we learned a lot and it was awesome
and now we're gonna try new experiences
and we love our baby girl and she's
gonna be okay
and every parent out there ask yourself
this
whose dream is this is this our dream
or is it our kid's dream and i can tell
you
all the way up until law school i would
talk to students who said i'm only here
because my dad says this is what i gotta
do
26 year olds who were burdened by their
dad's
dreams or i've met with med students i'm
only here because mom said i've got to
be a doctor
a 25 year old kid burdened with moms you
will do this
the best thing you can do for your kids
is to have an instrument in the room and
some balls in the room and some support
with the room
let them know they are tethered in and
they can try things and when you see
that spark come on
then you can lean on them we are people
who are accountable we are people who
show up for our teams we are people who
work real hard
and look at you you can do hard things
are you proud of yourself
did you put out an effort on the track
or on the on the pitch or on the
football field that you're proud of
then i'm proud of your effort right
i'm proud of your effort i'm proud that
you
overcame i'm proud that you stuck it out
now you're talking
now we're going to create a generation
of kids
who know how to work hard who know when
to say hey this one's not for me
who knows how to receive coaching and
push through hard things
but also does not get their self-esteem
from achievement and i know i'm talking
about a delicate balance here i know i
know
but that's what we're aiming for and
we're gonna get some messed wrong some
mess
right i'm gonna i'm gonna register for
my kid for jiu jitsu this summer
i'm i'm trading him baseball in the
spring for jiu-jitsu in the summer he's
not gonna like it
but i want him to go through hard things
i want him to experience that struggle
and then at the end i think he's gonna
overcome i think he's gonna begin to
love it but if he doesn't
i'm not going to get my identity through
a 11 or 12 year old jiu jitsu kid
i'm going to get my identity being a dad
who loves his son
all right thank you so much for your
call angela i love
your heart and you want to get it right
there's a lot to this after you have
this conversation with with your
daughter
after you say hey let's take the summer
off let's do something else
you're going to be the house planner
this summer we're dedicating this summer
to you
we're going to pay you for it and we
want you to join a summer camp or
girl scouts or want you to work at the
local church whatever that is
um let me know how that conversation
goes i'd love to report back to our
audience on this all right so as we wrap
up today's show
man off the 1995. this is one of my pop
punk favorites
and last week we went with some kind of
mushy songs
my metal friends think we're failing
here i even had a cold play in there
we're back off the 1995 album
outcome the wolves this is the most
sing-along
song on the record so don't get all
drummed out
but it's rancid's ruby soho and it goes
like this
echoes of reggae coming through my
bedroom wall having a party up next door
but i'm sitting here
all alone it's all about loneliness guys
two lovers in the bedroom and the other
starts to shout
and all i got is this blank stare and
that don't carry no clout at all
destination unknown ruby ruby ruby ruby
soho
he's singing and she's there to lend a
hand he's seen his name on the marquee
but she will never understand and once
again he's leaving and she's there with
a tear in her eye
embraces with a warm gesture it's time
time to say goodbye
destination unknown ruby ruby
ruby ruby soho check that song out
you'll sing it all day long the boys in
rancid this has been
the dr john dolone's show